What's up everybody!
We are Pongfinity
And welcome to another episode of
Challenge Pongfinity
This is the series where YOU
Challenge US
With your craziest ideas
Related to table tennis
If your idea gets picked
We will feature it in our next video
And give you a shout out
So make sure you leave your comments and ideas
In the comment-section below
It's time to take table tennis to the forest.
Thanks Joao Francisco Chanoca for the challenge.
This should be fun!
Funder Laustrup wants us to play with a saw
Thanks for watching guys
It was a a lot of fun making this episode,
hope you enjoyed it!
If you are new to the channel
Remember to subscribe here
And check out our other videos
There.
Until next time!